- [Voiceover] People at
work think I'm boring.
None of them know I'm a nudist.
(drums playing)
(whoosh)
- [Voiceover] The first
naked man I ever saw
looked like Santa.
I was eight and my mom had accidentally
brought us to a nudist commune
instead of a nature camp.
- [Voiceover] My Nana owns a nudist camp.
I like to go there and get naked.
It feels so light and free.
- [Voiceover] Cooking naked is dangerous.
Sincerely.
I've got polka-dotted boobs now.
- [Voiceover] Had to give a talk
at a nudist colony last week.
Didn't get nervous, I
just pictured them all
with their clothes on.
- [Voiceover] Family
nudism is getting more
difficult as our daughter gets older.
- [Voiceover] My roommate is a nudist.
I was not informed of this before we
signed the lease.
Slightly awkward.
- [Voiceover] My parents just told me
they're nudists when I'm not around.
And now want to do it when I'm home.
Not sure I want to see them naked.
- [Voiceover] My
sister-in-law has decided to
become a home nudist.
Outwardly, I'm saying,
"Well, if you're sure."
Inwardly, I'm saying, "Woo-hoo!
"Thank you Jesus!"
("Warm It Up" by Warner /
Chappell Production Music)
(whoosh)
(creak)